hi welcome to the monitor your weekly
look at the best in pop culture movies
TV comics video games music if it
determines the fate of the free world
then I'm going to sift through it just
for you well not you but be you yeah you
over there this week we're going to talk
about a couple of great comic books that
have just come out we're going to talk
about Max Payne 3 from Rockstar Games
which is coming out but first we're
going to talk about movies well there's
the Avengers but you've clearly already
seen the Avenger
okay we're going to stop you go see the
Avengers just press pause or something
and I'm going to talk to these other
people about a movie they haven't seen
yet how about how about Dark Shadows
Johnny Depp Tim Burton work together all
the time and I don't know look I get
that they love working together and I
get that they're out to revive like
every can't be franchise that they
possibly can I just don't know if a late
60s british soap opera about a vampire
who reawakens is really the the thing to
do today so instead of giving it the
kind of full review treatment we're
going to give it my cursory haiku of the
week Barnabas Collins means nothing to
most people but hey go for it bouse
deeply wait that that says that says
boughs deeply in and I'm sitting down
it's wired you said what's crowdsource
the cue cards yeah great good idea we're
going to get things straight here but
actually my co-host we've a
correspondent outside is going to talk
to you about a couple of great comic
books so let's let's just go to him I've
got a couple comic books check out this
week first one it's part of DC Comics
new 52 initiative last year they began
this universe reboot started with number
ones of 52 comic books second wave is
just starting up and kind of foremost
among those at least for me is dial H
written by China Mieville sci-fi that an
all-around badass and it's drawn by
Brazilian artist Matthias Santa loco
it's a modern day version of dial H
which is a mid 60's title from DC that's
also gotten a couple of reboots over the
years as before it's about civilian who
stumbles on a magical payphone payphone
hey hey anyway stumbles on a payphone
and if you dial the letters a TR 0 turns
you into a superhero and you fight crime
because that's what happens what's
different about this time around is that
the civilian is just a regular
middle-aged guy kind of a sad sack down
on his luck and what really shines is
Mabel's dialogue as always
is fantastic just like in his books the
the characters that he's bringing really
really just our fantastic the first
couple of heroes in this first issue
show you that he's going to some really
entertaining and actually funny
directions I'm sad to loco we may
remember if you've seen his heart in
verticals American vampire series are
also last year's idw reboot of Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles really versatile
and and his illustrations really bring a
sense of order some of the more chaotic
situations in the book speaking of idw
there's also another title you need to
check out the number one just started
for Frankenstein alive alive which is
written by steve niles from 30 days of
night fame and i illustrated by bernie
wrightson who actually almost 30 years
ago illustrated uh Mary Shelley's
original Frankenstein story so write
sins art and niles fantastic writing
just Mary really beautifully really
starkly drawn darkly told story of Frank
sighs monster after the events the book
after he's kind of parted ways with with
dr. Frankenstein himself seems like it's
going in some interesting direction so
by all means check that out so so that's
comic books ok thanks Peter what's left
Oh video games like I said and the video
game of the week is Max Payne 3 from
Rockstar Games who brought you of course
such educational fair as Grand Theft
Auto series bully red dead redemption
manhunt LA noire comes the latest in the
cop turned vigilante series that
everyone loves so much except this time
max payne is down in Brazil he's little
washed-up he's put on a little weight
he's basically a glorified bodyguard but
just like the others bullet time
technology which everyone loves comic
book influence and visuals now this is
the first max payne game that isn't done
by remedy entertainment or is written by
the series creator sam lake but given
rockstars track record over the past few
years it's a safe bet that this is going
to be just the thing to tide you over
until GTA 5 which is going to come
2016 nobody knows for sure so that's it
for this week thanks for coming to the
monitor inaugural edition and come back
next week for the best of pop culture
stuff that you can stuff into your brain
until then inspirational sign off
you